hallo herzlich willkommen zur verließ
welt ist das schon an der überschrift
also unser buch ist fertig und der
kochbuch so sieht's aus und es wollte
dir einfach kurz sagen nee also unser
buch ich mein kochbuch ist jetzt fertig
und ab heute könnt ihr das auch bekommen
wo er das bekommen könnte usw
das sage ich einfach am ende aber ich
wollte euch jetzt einfach kurzer bis
etwas über das buch erzählen weil ja
einfach damit ihr wisst wie das das
stande gekommen ist wie soll ich
überhaupt ein buch geschrieben habe was
das findbuch ist was alles drin steckt
und so weiter und wenn natürlich auch
die arbeit reingesteckt hat als das war
schon länger geplant
also ich würde sagen das war mein traum
schon immer gewesen im koch oder back
buch zu schreiben
aber es war einfach schon länger geplant
dass ich eine back buch schreibe und
einfach ein paar rezepte mit euch teilen
und natürlich wir waren da wirklich
schon sehr lange daran und haben auch
immer belegt wie machen wir das und mit
wem machen wird es ohne wurden von ganz
vielen verlagen angeschrieben die uns
dann noch angeboten haben eben ein buch
mit ihnen zu machen und dann eben raus
zu rauszubringen
und wir haben es bisher eben nicht
gemacht vor allem nicht mit einem großen
verlag weil ich einfach auch das selber
in die hand nehmen wollte also viele
bieten die dann einfach an wir machen
ein interview über die ich wir schreiben
ein porträt über dich und dann gibst du
uns deine rezepte und wir schreiben sie
wir machen die fotos aber ich wollte es
einfach alles nicht ich wollte es alles
selber machen selber die texte schreiben
selber die fotos machen also nicht ich
aber mit hilfe von mir und einfach hier
hat das ganze selber in die hand nehmen
weil das finde ich einfach so was
persönliches was privates ist und
einfach soll einfach mein werk sein
deswegen haben wir das bisher eigentlich
nicht gemacht obwohl ich schon lange
drauf gewartet habt ich hab mir echt
immer eine anfrage gehabt dann bringst
du endlich mal ein buch heraus und ja so
war eigentlich so die grundidee und
dieses jahr wollten wir eigentlich keins
mehr machen weil einfach die zeit nicht
gereicht hätte auch mit der
schwangerschaft mit der lh mit der
sanierer und ich hätte es einfach
alleine nicht hinbekommen im monat das
war einfach bisserl zu viel gewesen und
dieses jahr hatten wir unsere sendung
auf galileo bei prosieben und nach
dieser sendung hat
ein päckchen im briefkasten also
eigentlich das päckchen nicht an mich
gerichtet sondern an die samira und zwar
von der lebens simone di simone hat den
eigenen verlag das ist ein klitzekleiner
verlag wirklich da ist sie mit dabei sie
schreibt ihre geschichten und hat
einfach 23 personen um sich herum
die dann noch die bilder malen die noch
eben alles außen herum machen und das
sind jetzt einfach so schöne märchen
also eigentlich diese typischen märchen
die man kennt aber ganz anders
geschrieben also richtig modern auch
finde ich zum beispiel rotkäppchens wolf
rumpelstilzchen jule rapunzel und der
froschkönig und der froschkönig war zum
beispiel das erste buch was uns am ihrer
gelesen hat und angeschaut hat und auch
angehört hat denn da gibt es auch eine
cd mit dabei und es ist so musicals buch
also die kinder können sich die
geschichten anschauen
einsam ihrer kinder noch nicht lesen und
kann praktisch mit lesen und sich
gleichzeitig auch die lieder anhören das
war wirklich so schön zu sehen einfach
wie samira tag für tag in dem zimmer
dann darf mit der cdu und mit dem buch
und es war wirklich toll und ich war
dann selber auch so begeistert weil ich
merke kinderbücher selber sowieso gern
als grundschullehrerin ich habe auch
ganz wieder kinderbücher aber das war
wirklich das erste mal dass samira
wirklich so lange an den büchern
gesessen war
ja und dann habe ich einfach die simone
angerufen und mich bei ihm bedankt
natürlich für die bücher und habe
einfach mal gesagt komm simone dafür
dass du mir jetzt die bilder geschickt
hat kommt doch einfach mal vorbei
also es war dann so die sie wird auch
nicht weit weg sie wohnen in reutlingen
und sicher da wo der rat auch herkommt
geld das ich bei dir in der nähe
die schwäbische verbundenheit solche
sympathie war da aber die partner sind
sympathisch das muss ich dir sagen gegen
flensburg spielt ja auf jeden fall kam
die simone dann vorbei und wir haben sie
einfach mal mit ihr unterhalten
und wer mich kennt weiß ich bin ja
eigentlich grundschullehrerin und
eigentlich wollte ich immer in der zeit
als ich grundschullehrerin noch war
wollte ich eigentlich immer selber auch
mal kinderbücher nicht schreiben aber
ich wollte dazu malen und ich hatte
immer gedacht dass meine freundin nadja
alle geschichten schreibt du nicht mal
dann dazu und es war ich immer so unsere
grundidee und deswegen haben uns dann
einfach mal mit dass simone darüber
unterhalten ob wenn ich mal zusammen und
buch machen wenn sie schon ihren verlag
hat und auch diese ganzen tollen ideen
und eben auch mit den musicals also ich
fand es einfach richtig schön jan haben
wir uns einfach so unterhalten mit ihr
und irgendwie war dann für sie halt
total überraschend weil sie halt gesagt
hat sie schon ganz kleiner verlag und
hat bisher hat alles immer alleine
gemacht und sie war eigentlich total
überwältigt das wisse gefragt ob wir
nicht mehr zusammen was machen
es war echt schön ihre tochter war auch
mit dabei ist war echt schön
ja und so hat eigentlich dann die idee
angefangen dass wir mit ihr zusammen und
buch machen wollen aber es war
eigentlich gedacht ich mache ein
kinderbuch also so praktisch die
grundschule für kindergärten usw
ja und irgendwie weist ein bisschen
immer wieder ins gespräch gekommen und
dann habe ich gedacht wenn wir schon so
ein buch machen dann muss man auch ein
paar rezepte mit reinkommen und so hat
sich das eigentlich entwickelt und dann
erzählt uns diesem monat dass sie auch
noch in anderen verlag gegründeten
kleinen und zwar den echt lecker verlag
und zwar schreibt man damit also echt
lecker und da geht eben auch um
rezeptbücher und irgendwie stand so die
idee entstanden okay ich mache so ein
geschichtenbuch mit rezepten für kinder
und das machen wir dann über ihren
kleinen echt lecker verlag und ja
irgendwie haben wir dann die idee immer
weiter gesponnen und ich habe dann
gesagt ich möchte jetzt erstmal mit
einem kleinen buch starten weil ein
großes backbuch möchte ich sowieso
irgendwann mal machen aber dass wir
einfach mal so bei 1 anfangen und so uns
jetzt gleich übernehmen und einfach mal
wissen wie startet man das und ich meine
die branche auch die erfahrung die
könnten ja die deponie simone hat er
genau dass sich hat erfahren die sie
hatte und die wie halt net haben und
deswegen erhalte sagt wir starten jetzt
einfach mal klein und fangen einfach mal
so mit einem kinderbuch an
ja und das hat sich halt immer so weiter
entwickelt dann habe ich einfach
angefangen rezepte zu sammeln und mir
auszudenken haben kategorien geschrieben
haben wir alle meine ideen
aufgeschrieben und hab dann eigentlich
ziemlich schnell gemerkt dass es mit
einem kleinen buch eigentlich nicht
getan ist
ja weil ich bereit und so viele hundert
seiten wollen geflogen ja eigentlich 100
seiten gedacht und so im rahmen so 14 15
euro
das war einfach so da so 30 rezepte
ungefähr haben und ja dabei blieb es
dann nicht weil einfach immer mehr ideen
ein
gefallen sind und ich dann gedacht habe
konnte die idee nicht weglassen also
nehme ich auch noch mit rein und das
noch mit rein und haben mit 23 rezepten
ich kann meine frühstücks kategorie
machen und danach nur drei frei machen
deswegen wurde halt ein dickes buch
draus und ja das war also die anfangs
geschichte und deswegen heißt das buch
auch selig rezepte für kinder
aber es ist jetzt nicht so dass das
rezept drin sind die nur für kinder sind
es ist jetzt mehr so geworden dass ich
einfach auch ganz normale rezepte
gemacht habt also nicht wieso normale
kinder kochbücher dass ich jetzt sagen
okay ich backe kuchen und das sieht
jetzt aus wie ein pandabär und deswegen
finden den kinder toll
nee ich hab's halt so gemacht ich habe
viele tolle rezepte gesammelt aus
verschiedenen kategorien
ich habe frühstück mittagessen snacks
und salate die drinking ich habe
gedrängt wird desserts süßes aus dem
backofen ohne weihnachts kategorien und
die habe ich als kunterbunt gefüllt auch
mit teilweise also ist sie nicht so ganz
einfache rezepte nur sondern sind auch
hauptgerichte mit drin bei schwarz
gebackenes mit drin aber ebenso erklärt
dass es auch kinder verstehen können und
auch deftige sachen auch deftige sachen
und der murat hat auch gesagt dass ich
ein buch für ihn weil es auch versteht
genau welche schritte hat ein so
erklärte für eltern gehen auch für
männer jetzt vielleicht noch ganz kurz
zu den rezepten in den verschiedenen
kategorien
also ich hab halt darauf geachtet dass
ich es sind jetzt nicht nur einfache
rezepte so dass ihr jetzt denkt
irgendwie ich nehme brot und schnell was
drauf ist den rezepte mit einfachen
zutaten also mit zutaten die man immer
da hat die man überall bekommt ich
wollte keine außergewöhnlichen
exotischen zutaten nehmen sondern
einfach alltagstaugliche rezepte dann
auch machen weil oft ist so uns geht es
auch so ich steht dann auf morgen sind
denken wir auch hier was frühstücke ich
heute also habe ich ihr frühstücks idee
mit dabei die einfach abwechslungsreich
sind wo man sagt okay heute essen müsli
morgen wache ich mir im brot was es sich
zu mittag denn oft ist immer das problem
man hat einfach keine idee oder braucht
einfach seine inspiration und deswegen
habe ich hier zum beispiel auch viele
hauptgerichte mit drin
die wirklich sehr lecker sind die aber
trotzdem aus einfachen zutaten gemacht
sind
ihr müsst nicht irgendwie extra ingo
einkaufen gehen weil ich einfach alles
da habt und vor allem finde ich so toll
weil
ich habe es eher mit samira zusammen
gemacht also wir haben nicht alle
rezepte dann auch zusammen gekocht und
gebacken und ich habe dann einfach auch
bei ihr gesehen dass es halt bei ihr gut
ankommt und ich meine schwester mira
kennt weiß es ist neben murat eigentlich
mein größter kritiker erstmal sagt mama
das schmeckt nicht gute sagt sie oft
einfach um mich zu ärgern aber ich habe
einfach gesehen es macht ihr spaß nudeln
selber zu machen für ihre eigene
nudelsuppe und ja es war einfach toll
dass so mit zu erleben auch und das hat
mir einfach auch gezeigt okay die
rezepte kommt bei ihr gut ankommt bei
murat gut an
und deswegen hoffe ich denke auch dass
der bei euch gut ankommen einfach weil
jeder einfach mal so eine inspiration
braucht und so eine kleine anregung und
dann kann man sagen okay so mache ich
das heute wichtig war mir auch dass ich
in dem buch so ein bisschen was über
ernährung erzähle
also warum ich mich auch für dieses
kinder oder warum ich jetzt auch kinder
kochbuch geschrieben habe ist man kann
ja seine ernährung eigentlich von grund
auf bzw die eltern liegen eigentlich die
grundstein
das heißt da geht es dann um die
frühkindliche geschmacksbildung wenn ich
als kind zum beispiel immer nur
fertigprodukte esse dann wird es mir
später etwas schwerer fallen einfach mal
auch natürliche sachen zu essen weil ich
dann den geschmack schon gewohnt bin von
dem ganzen totomat von den
geschmacksverstärkern und ich später so
diese natürliche zutaten eigentlich gar
nicht mehr mag das problem hatten wir
zwar ja auch also meine mama zum
beispiel die hat immer ganz frisch
gekocht klar gab es bei uns daheim auch
mal magie aber das hat meine schwester
auf iran gemacht aber es war halt bei
murat zb so er war viele fertig sachen
gewohnt weil er auch früher daheim
ausgezogen war und jetzt sehe ich gerade
eine ganze geschichte war auf bis zu
kaufen die wesentlichen nicht so gewohnt
einfach viele fertigprodukte zu essen
und als ich dann angefangen habe für ihn
zu kochen hatte halt erstmal alles immer
noch mal über würzen müssen uns hat ihm
einfach am anfang gar nicht geschmeckt
ich mach dich fertig aber so durch die
gewohnt also eher kunst eine gewohnheit
auch wieder umstellen und jetzt
mittlerweile ist da eigentlich ganz
normal und ganz natürlich also grad ich
wurde geheilt ich bin jetzt ein ganz
normaler und vorher war ich total wird
ich hoffe ihr versteht was ich meine man
kann einfach den grundstein in der
kindheit schon
auch im mutterleib zum beispiel schon
und das war mir einfach auch ganz
wichtig tut mir leid wenn ich gedacht
habe ich auch immer
allein im ort ab und mir was halt
wichtig dass ich die rezepte genau
erklären sowie hat auch in meinen videos
dass ich sehr anschaulich erklären das
heißt ich habe auch oft step by step
bilder mit dabei und das ist einfach ja
auch so drumherum ein bisschen was
erzählt wird das heißt ich habe in
meinem buch jetzt auch geschrieben was
ist mir am frühstück wichtig was ist am
mittag essen wichtig was haben wir zum
beispiel zuhause für rituale beim essen
was man überhaupt für rituale zu hause
so ein bisschen was aus der
familiengeschichte
also einfach so ein komplettpaket
einfach so wie wir alt sind und wie wir
auch leben und das habe ich eben alles
hier mit reingepackt ja ich habe auch
eine seite der moral was überzeugen
bieten kann zeigt hinten ganz hinten
solid snake ich später also murat hat
auch seine seite ich musste sie mich
habe die beim familiengericht eingeklagt
ich wollte mich keiner haben aber schaut
mal wahnsinn oder hat sogar ein foto mit
drin unglaublich und du hast doch gar
nicht nur zweifel große reichweiten
haben mich groß geschrieben durch groß
geschrieben
daraus übrigens so gemacht
naja werden murat kennt und weiß wie er
schreibt er schreibt fehlerfrei aber wir
haben uns gedacht nach spahns
direktoriums wird zu teuer
die aus dem rechtsstaat viel drin ja ich
mir auf der karriereseite aber aber erst
als auch sagt er wie es hat so lasse
weil es ist eher so dass ich nicht und
ohne rechtschreibfehler sagen dass ich
nicht morgen
es war übrigens die deutsche seite
ja und ich fand das jetzt wirklich auch
sehr gut dass ich das buch jetzt mit
dass simone gemacht habe in diesem monat
einfach die erfahrung dadurch dass sie
eben selber ihre bücher auch
veröffentlicht und sie konnte mir
einfach dabei helfen dass ich zum
beispiel eine richtige druckerei
aussuchen konnte
ich hätte zum beispiel mein buch auch in
fernost drucken können für einen
bruchteil dessen was ich jetzt hier
gezahlt habe aber ich wollte einfach
eine druckerei die ihre bücher eben noch
so druckt wie eben das druckerhandwerk
ist ich meine demokratisch
auch selber drucker auszudrucken
aufsetzt drucker und heute gibt es auch
eine andere bezeichnung ja das heißt
drucktechnologie das hat sich natürlich
so schavan sieht bei den beruf bleiben
sollen als ich das gewusst hätte hätte
jetzt ist gedrückt ich wäre auch der
beste obst drucker der welt gewesen von
welt gewesen
ja auf jeden fall was mir sehr wichtig
dass eben die druckerei eben das
handwerk noch ausübt aber auch dass sie
zwölf ihre mitarbeiter verbessert er
bezahlen was zum beispiel in fernost
eben nicht der fall wäre
und deswegen war es mir also ich hab das
dann deswegen in kauf genommen das buch
dann ebenso jetzt nicht so billig wird
wie jetzt aus dem fernost aber einfach
nicht sally gewesen hätte ich das eben
so gemacht weil ich lege auch von meinen
zutaten immer wert darauf dass die aus
der region stammen und deswegen war mir
das eben bei meinem buch auch sehr
wichtig weil das buch einfach mich und
meine persönlichkeit widerspiegelt und
es sollte einfach das komplettpaket
stimmen
ja und was ich auch noch im buch mit
drin habe das habe ich ganz hinten mit
drin
das beste kommt zum schluss ich hab noch
meinen team mit drin und zwar habe ich
hier einfach ein paar seiten hier zum
beispiel der frank die jessy die uns
unterstützt haben hier die sabine unter
schavan vom shop kennt ihr
wahrscheinlich jeder marius der unsere
fotos gemacht hat und hier die simone
und natürlich hinten der murat
wahrscheinlich beabsichtigt dass du ganz
zum schluss kommt das beste ich weiß ich
weiß ganz genau die leute das buch
kaufen
ja auf jeden fall beim marius sind er
hat unsere ganzen fotos gemacht und wir
standen wirklich tage lang hinten in
meiner küche das war im hochsommer bei
40 grad haben die ich habe die rezepte
gemacht er hat nebenher schon so dem
tisch gerichtet dekoration gerichtet
werden es zusammen umgestellt und zwar
wirklich schön das alles zu machen
vor allem seine bild auf instagram also
wenn wir auf instagram folgt da habe ich
ja die samira ein foto von sanierer
reingestellt mit wintermütze schal und
allem wirklich es war wie es bei 40 grad
steilen scanner nicht food stylist food
fotograf da gibt es ein unterschied
also wir haben die rezepte gemacht also
ich hab sie gemacht und hab es einfach
angerichtet und wir haben sie einfach so
gelassen wie sie auch sinn also ohne
dass er jetzt noch her
kam mit haarspray und haarlack und
irgendwie er hat mir erzählt dass man
zum beispiel im fernsehen bei
schokoladen werbung oder auch auf fotos
nicht schokolade benutzt und das erdöl
mit farbe
damit die schönsten szenen geologisch
temperatur und klar aber wahrscheinlich
viel zu aufwändig da echte schokolade zu
nehmen aber mir war es halt wichtig dass
meine rezepte und meine speisen zu
fotografiert werden wie sie sind und da
markus arbeitet einfach mit ein bisschen
dekoration mit licht und mit schärfe und
ich finde die fotos sind wunderschön
geworden
also dann braucht man wirklich nett
irgendwie war sie erst in zwei bis
fotograf der welt also der beste bist du
ja so ist es ja das war mir auch ganz
besonders wichtig dass dies natürlich
sind und ich finde die auch echt schön
und ich wäre auch gern mit auf den
weihnachts fotos gewesen aber mir war es
einfach viel zu warm was langes
anzuziehen bericht umfasst
fachhochschulen ich war hochschwanger
oder das schöne
also mein buch gibt es natürlich in
meinem online shops ellis shop.de da
könnt ihr es bekommen und es wird auch
hier in waghäusel in der im globus-markt
geben
jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht
globus-markt auch ich denke viele frage
ist es nicht denn ihr wisst ich gehe
einfach immer zum globus einkaufen und
ich habe da ja auch schon mehrere back
aktionen gemacht und andere aktionen und
deswegen wird es dort geben
wahrscheinlich wird es auch in mehreren
globus märkten in ganz deutschland geben
und ansonsten wird das buch auch in
kleinen büchereien geben aber da legt
wert darauf dass es einfach so
familienunternehmen sind also richtig
schöne kleine schnuckelige büchereien
haben wir auch im ort welche oder eine
die ich auch seit meiner kindheit
eigentlich immer besucher und immer wenn
ich was gebraucht habe bin ich da hin da
bekommt man eine tolle beratung da
kriegt man auch mal eine tasse kaffee
oder tee angeboten kann sich reinsetzen
kann in bücher reinschnuppern und das
finde ich einfach ganz toll und es sind
dann einfach ausgesuchte bücherläden
entwickeln bestellen
ihr könnt es dann bei uns bestellen und
wir also ich wäre dann einfach
entscheiden welche davon ich beliefere
um mir ist einfach wirklich wichtig dass
es familienunternehmen sind und nicht so
große konzerne ich meine ihr habt ihr
jetzt gemerkt ich lege wert darauf dass
ich das buch selber mache ich lege wert
darauf mit wem ich zusammenarbeite ich
lege wert drauf wo das buch gedruckt
wird und deswegen lege ich eben auch
wertvolles buch verkauft wird
und so habe ich einfach über meinen job
und über die globus märkte über die
kleinen büchereien einfach die kontrolle
und hab da einfach und gutes gewissen
mit dabei ich glaube das buch ich
einfach bio eier essen kann es nicht und
jetzt vielleicht noch so ein paar fragen
zum buch die mir schon gestellt wurden
auf instagram facebook und youtube
viele haben natürlich gefragt ob ich das
buch signieren kann das problem ist
einfach über den shop das geht einfach
nicht weil das einfach zeitlich nicht
hinhauen würde und viele wollen zum
beispiel auch vom uran mit signatur
murat ich weiß nicht warum aber das
funktioniert einfach nicht so murat
arbeitet ja auch und wir würden es
einfach zeitlich und organisatorisch
nicht hinbekommen aber ich würde euch
einfach vor schlagen wir sind ja auch
nächstes jahr auf vielen messen also 55
messen mindestens ich glaube so classics
also auf fünf jahren auf jeden fall gibt
in ganz deutschland verteilt das sagen
wir euch auf jeden fall noch bescheid
und dann würde ich anbieten dass ich die
euch dann dort signieren kann was noch
häufig die frage war wie wir soll wie
viel zeit müssen es sind insgesamt 262
seiten mit sally also alles von mir und
ich finde schon ziemlich faszinierend so
garnicht saison tabletten mit obst und
gemüse sollten nicht mehr da könnte dann
nachschauen welches obst welches gemüse
hat grad saison und das habe ich eben
auch in meinen rezepten berücksichtigt
und auch ihr habt ja auch gesehen dass
die rezepte eben nicht nur für kinder
sind auch wenn jetzt drauf steht felix
rezepte für kinder
aber es ist wirklich für groß und klein
was dabei für kinder und für männer und
für frauen die hier für singles und für
verheiratete paare und für
alleinstehende und für eigentlich für
alle wirbt das heißt halt so damit
natürlich auch oft gefragt was für
rezepte drin sind also es sind wirklich
alles neue rezepte ich glaube nur zwei
oder drei rezepte habe ich von meinem
blog übernommen weil es einfach tolle
rezepte waren wie zb samir als limonade
und ansonsten ist wirklich alles neu und
das ist jetzt auch so mein erstes buch
als es wird natürlich noch ein buch
geben wo ich auch torten motiv torten
klassische torten und so weitermachen
und wir haben jetzt auch schon geplant
ein buch zu machen mit orientalischen
und mediterranen rezepten weil da
einfach die nachfrage auch immer sehr
groß ist also da freue ich mich jetzt
auch schon drauf und da machen wir uns
dann auch so langsam im neuen jahr an
die planung und an die gestaltung an die
ideensammlung wobei die ideen haben wir
eigentlich schon
wahrscheinlich werden jetzt viele auf
den shop gehen und das buch bestellen
wollen und bitte habt nachsicht falls
der shop zusammenbricht ich habe einfach
er wird zusammenbrechen jawohl brot ist
mir jetzt schon leid erst letzte woche
geschafft dass die seite eines regional
einer regionalen zeitung
zusammengebrochen ist deswegen denke ich
dass wir und haben einfach verlinkt auf
facebook und dann gegen die seite
plötzlich mit uns im zusammenhang geben
deswegen haben nachsicht falls ist jetzt
nicht gleich klappt es wird
funktionieren
schreiber streifen beschreibt
eine e mail an info at least orten
welt.de und ja ich hoffe dass euch das
buch gefallen wird wären wirklich sehr
viel arbeit reingesteckt sehr viel
herzblut und es war zwar sehr
anstrengend aber es war auch sehr schön
vor allem jetzt endlich dieses fertigen
exemplare in der hand zu halten also
schon was ganz besonderes weil ja man
steckt einfach viel zeit rein und viel
arbeit und viele ideen und das buch
haben wir theoretisch er schon das nicht
wir sind ja keine exemplare
da fehlt noch der lack ja das ist jetzt
ich hab jetzt sagt der druckerei dass
ich gerne ein exemplar hätte um das
video zu machen und ist damit per hand
gebunden das ist doch der wahnsinn oder
das exemplar das müsste eigentlich einen
rahmen das ist übrigens erst heute
geliefert
jetzt ist montag genau heute also wenn
man eingeht ist montag
heute ist im shop auf lager und es ist
wahrscheinlich gerade die paletten ange
wahrscheinlich und das muss jetzt alle
rollen grad genau also jetzt mir auch
momentan wahrscheinlich gerade im shop
und tun jetzt die ganzen packen ihre
nachbarn helfen uns da nicht ich muss
dabei sein auf jeden fall also die ganze
stadt hilft uns das zu packen
ja also ich hoffe euch gefällt euch ich
würde mich freuen wenn ihr mir ein
feedback dazu schreibt auf facebook auf
instagram auf youtube da bin ich schon
sehr gespannt darauf vor allem wenn ihr
die rezepte nach macht und die dann auch
mit foto rein stellen wo man der seite
liest weil drei seiten ließ könnt ihr
mir auch ein feedback zu fleisch das
nächste buch von mir kann auch sein rat
und seine doofe sprüche neu sagt
lebensweisheiten
alles klar also viel spaß und vielen
dank für eure unterstützung
bis zum nächsten mal so viele sehen und
diese woche geht es noch ganz tolle
rezepte